all right so this is an iPhone 14 plus
pretty big phone but how big do you
think the biggest iPhone in the world is
so I wasn't expecting this but YouTuber
Matthew beam told me he was building the
world's biggest iPhone a few days ago
and then he showed up with it this thing
is fully functional seven feet tall and
weighs close to 500 pounds it has a
power button here there's also volume
buttons and a mute switch it's so tall
you have to get up on a ladder to take a
selfie with the camera because it's all
the way up here but you know I am the
tech YouTuber so I kind of had to
investigate a little bit into how he
made this and first of all watch his
video for my full reaction on the thing
but turns out there is no iPhone
actually in here at all it's actually a
Mac Mini in here which simulates running
a virtual Android phone and then that
Android phone is running a launcher that
makes it look like an iPhone all with
some jail rig Tech on the edges to make
it see where your finger is to make it
act like a touch screen all that to say
it's not an iPhone technically but it is
still pretty impressive